Justin Bieber may be off the market but
you won't see him rocking his wedding
ring just yet
while the sorry see her is legally
married to hailey Baldwin a source tells
ET quote justin is telling friends he
isn't planning on wearing a wedding band
for a while our source adds it will most
likely be when the couple has a more
formal ceremony with family and friends
we have a good time together he's just
really sweet he's a good kid a good
heart Halley and Justin seemed to be in
newlywed bliss after secretly tying the
knot in New York City last month it was
really special moment for me but it's no
secret that the couple is public about
their romance with PDA field trips and
pics they didn't want to make it a
spectacle our et source says quote that
is why they kept their marriage under
wraps
it's an amazing feeling pressure we're
told mr. and mrs. Bieber are marching to
the beat of their own drum when it comes
to their relationship keeping everyone
close to them on their toes our source
says earlier this month another et
source said the lovebirds didn't want to
wait to be married this comes just a few
months after Justin popped the question
to the 21 year old model in the Bahamas
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]